c'est un nouveau revers pour facebook
deux ans après le scandale cambridge
analytica les révélations autour de la
vente de données personnelles
d'utilisateurs du géant du web avait
amorcé un mouvement de protestation
contre le réseau et ce sont notamment
les mêmes craintes qui ont poussé le
cern l'organisation européenne pour la
recherche nucléaire a cessé d'utiliser
workplace le service de communication
internes développés par le réseau social
perdre le contrôle de nos données était
inacceptable tout comme payer pour un
outil ne faisant pas partie de l'offre
de services de base proposé à la
communauté du cern
il a donc été décidé de mettre un terme
à l'essai de cette plateforme facebook
perd ainsi un client prestigieux lancée
en 2016 workplace est un outil de
communication internes développés par le
réseau social qui permet à ses
utilisateurs d'échanger des messages et
des fichiers et de stocker des données
commune mais le passage de la plate
forme un système d'abonnement payant et
selon le groupe américain la raison qui
a poussé le cern à prendre sa décision
à l'origine le cern bénéficier de la
gratuité de notre offre premium et nous
lui avons proposé deux options celle de
payer pour notre service ou celle de
passer à notre version gratuite
ils ont refusé pour des raisons de coût
l'entreprise de mark zuckerberg se
désole de la décision de l'organisation
européenne pour la recherche nucléaire
et rappelle que les services proposés
respectent les normes en matière de
sécurité de confidentialité facebook
héros passage les milliers de membres de
la communauté du cern qui s'était créé
un conte noir place